hello everyone in this video we'll talk
about
type 1 autoimmune diabetes
so type 1 autoimmune diabetes leads to
destruction
of the pancreatic beta cells which
secretes
insulin as a result body would
face a very low level of insulin
this results in high blood glucose level
and low glucose mobilization to the
tissues
before understanding the nitty gritty
details of optimum diabetes the
complicated
immune responses we should take it
slowly and start from the very basics
so you must be familiar with the term
sugar
and you must have heard this term from
your father or grandfather
so what does that mean the medical term
of it
is known as diabetes
so diabetes simply means
elevated blood sugar sugar level and
there could be consequences
associated with it but wait a second
why elevated blood glucose level is bad
in fact our body use carbohydrate
protein fat as their fuel
and specially if body has choice it
would be
driven more towards carbohydrate
utilization
so why at all carbohydrate is bad the
point is
carbohydrate is not bad neither is
glucose
but when can when body cannot mobilize
glucose
then it it is bad so in
diabetes there is glucose
but body cannot utilize it after a meal
when the blood glucose level is elevated
in a normal person
it would be moving to the muscle liver
or adipose tissues
for utilization but for a diabetic
patient
this process is not happening
utilization of glucose is hampered so
even if
glucose is there body cannot utilize it
and that brings out the complication the
excess amount of glucose in the blood
might have severe consequences now there
could be many reasons for diabetes
and over 30 million of people in
u.s are affected by diabetes
annually 100 billion dollar
is spent on diabetes related medications
so the situation is severe right and the
situation is not good globally
because in south asia or western pacific
countries
the incidence is increasing day by day
so let's say you have taken a
meal full of glucose now what would
happen
is your blood glucose level would
increase but after the steep increase
it would also decrease because body
would try to utilize that glucose
and mobilize that glucose into several
tissues such as muscle adipose tissues
or liver
and that is happening in the normal
person
but this phenomena is not true for a
diabetic individual
his blood glucose level would be
increased
and stay in an elevated level for very
long time
because body is finding it difficult to
mobilize the glucose
now our pancreatic beta cell secretes
insulin
which is a peptide hormone and it takes
crucial
role for glucose mobilization
and insulin is secreted by the
pancreatic beta cells
so obviously if your pancreatic beta
cells are
dying then insulin level would be low
and there is another type of diabetes
which is type 2 diabetes where our body
gets
resistant to insulin that means our body
cannot
respond to insulin in the first case our
body can't
secrete insulin due to the destruction
of the
source and the second case even if there
is insulin body cannot respond to it so
these two
things are different our focus is type 1
diabetes in this video
so there are many genetic factors and
immune components which leads to the
complication of
type 1 autoimmune disease one major
thing is human leukocyte antigen
which give rise to mhc molecules but one
allele which is dr3 hladr3 and hlrdr4
are found to be associated with diabetic
individuals which are suffering who are
suffering from type 1 diabetes
so these pancreatic beta cells
they have insulin and they have many
surface markers
and our own body treat them as foreign
and generates
auto antibodies against them these
generation of auto antibodies might have
consequences
because cells like macrophages and
dendritic cells
would recognize these auto antibodies
with its fc receptor
now these macrophages and dendritic cell
can instantly
secrete inflammatory cytokines such as
il1
il6 and tnf alpha this this leads to
attraction of many other cell types and
increased inflammation
it attracts th 1 sub-population of cells
and many other cell types
moreover any cell type can show its
self antigen displayed on class 1 mhc
molecule
and this pancreatic beta cell also do
the same
but these antigens which is not supposed
to be detected as
foreign is now detected as foreign by
our cytotoxic t
cell and as a result hydroxic t cells
secretes perforin
and granzyme kills the
pancreatic beta cell now once pancreatic
beta cell is destroyed
there would be very less insulin which
is secreted right so
here you can see on the left hand side
there is the normal distribution of
pancreatic beta cell
which has dramatically reduced in an
individual suffering from type 1
diabetes
and that's the major cause and the major
pathophysiological symptom
and as a result you can clearly
understand when insulin level is low
there is no blood glucose mobilization
or very
less blood glucose mobilization and as a
result blood glucose level would be high
or elevated for a long time
which leads to many adverse consequences
in type 1 diabetes now there are many
solutions to type 1 diabetes one primary
solution
is to take more insulin from external
source
now body needs insulin after meal to
mobilize glucose and body simply can
produce it so
putting insulin from external source
would help in this case so
the stages of diabetes type 1 is the
following there is a genetic risk
immune activation immune response and
there would be detection phases
and these there are many individuals
which have different genetic
makeup who are more susceptible to type
1 diabetes
and in a different video i'll be talking
more about that
but this video was an overall summary
about the immune reaction that happens
in autoimmune type 1
diabetes and its complications so i hope
you enjoyed this video if you like this
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe
and please follow me on patreon you can
support my channel by paying me in
patreon
small support can really help my channel
to grow
and my courses are present in an academy
in order to access the full fledged
course
you can use my code ap10 to get a 10
discount by the way who don't know about
unacademy
it's india's biggest learning platform
so you can
join there and access my courses thank
you guys thanks for listening